all right everyone um my name is lauren
ressler i'm your host for this session
and with me today we have tonya sims
who'll be talking about the face of fun
with python frameworks fast api versus
flash 2.0
tonya was voted into the wisconsin
basketball hall of fame i like that fact
that a
former professional and collegiate girl
basketball player turned pythonista tony
simpson is currently a python developer
advocate for
vonage
tonya started her technology career
working as an executive assistant for a
leading financial investment company in
the iit department she transitioned into
a computer operator role and started
learning how to code eventually she
worked her way up from an entry-level
position to earn roles as a software
engineer and test and software developer
contracting with some of the top
financial service companies in chicago
she's passionate about helping other
engineers and loves to see people
succeed so
welcome and the floor is yours thank you
i'm going to share my screen
so everybody welcome uh
welcome to our fun face-off between fast
api and flash 2.0
uh so i just want to just quickly uh
cover what we are going to be chatting
about during our time together um so we
are going to go on a hero's journey uh
that's first and foremost
uh hero's journey is a popular story
structure made famous by joseph campbell
used in greek mythology and other
stories and so i'll quickly set up our
story uh and we'll use this hero's
journey format all throughout this talk
uh then we'll start our fun face off
between fast api and flash 2.0
and so during this face-off between
these two python web frameworks uh here
are some errors that we'll go over uh
we're going to talk about how to set up
a quick hello world application
uh we'll talk about http methods
focusing on a post method uh we're going
to talk about automatic documentation
which is like an interactive
documentation in the browser uh that
will make your life a lot easier when
you're debugging
and so we're also going to chat about
how to do data validation uh in both
flask and fast api and how something
called pedantic helps uh helps you with
providing user friendly uh errors when
data is invalid uh we'll talk about the
templates folder used for serving out
html files for web applications and
lastly we'll cover running in production
using
whiskey or
versus asgi and why you want to use one
over the other
and lastly we'll choose why you use fast
api over flask and vice versa
lastly make sure you stay until the end
because i have a freebie for you so
so sit back and relax and let's go on
this hero's journey together
so i feel your pain okay imagine you're
like banging your head against the wall
at work uh trying to choose between
these python web frameworks flask 2.0
versus fast api
and as if your day couldn't get any
worse your boss comes to you on a friday
okay with 15 minutes left in your day
and he says i need a huge favor and
you're thinking to yourself
oh my god like what could he possibly
need right now before the weekend and he
says we just want our biggest customer
ever
and i need you to choose between fast
api and flash today
and you're like today
you're not sure if you can do it because
you have plans with your friends and
family later on
so you commit the cardinal send
and you ask your boss can i do it on
monday and your boss looks very angry
and he starts shaking and trembling and
then his body becomes engulfed in a
tornado he's swallowed right in the
middle of it his skin is like ripping
apart
and he turns into the evil internet ice
lady and you're like okay what the shape
shifter pack is going on here
and she easily laughs ha ha ha you
choose between flash 2.0 and flash api
today or else i will use my powers to
freeze the internet forever
so you quickly think to yourself oh my
god if the internet is frozen
i won't be able to watch avengers or
binge watch loki or square games
then you say to the evil and red eyes
lady okay i'll do it under one condition
i need to slin send a slack message to
someone
with malice in her voice she asks who
might that be
and you say my tech lead
so hi i'm tanya once again uh and i'm a
former pro athlete from pythonista so
along with python you may see some
sports references today during this
story uh and as florian said i'm
currently a python developer advocate
advantage which is a leading
communications api provider
you can use our apis to build
application using video voice and text
messaging and much more
so before we continue with our story
um and our fast api versus flask 2.0
face-off um i just want to set some
expectations so i might go back to the
basics sometimes because
you know everybody here might be at
different learning levels um and i don't
know about you but when i first started
learning how to code uh it felt like my
head was going to explode especially
because i started learning how to code
in c-sharp
thank god for python uh
so uh
yeah so definitely type in the chat like
what was your journey like when you
first started coding and how is it going
now uh i would love to learn more about
you like you can even tell me who your
favorite sports teams are or if you've
used like you know fast api or flask or
django or any other web python framework
so just let me know in the comments and
we'll talk about it after uh after this
after our talk
so back to our story
so
uh you just finished messaging your talk
lead right and she gave you like a major
pep talk she's like
you put in all this hard work and you
know you
all the new things that you've learned
over the last several months like you
can definitely do this challenge and
save the internet
so now you're feeling super
okay and you feel confident that you can
pass this evil internet nice ladies
challenge and save the world from frozen
internet
so let our face off of
class 2.0 and fast api begin
the evil internet i said he barks at you
she's like tell me how fast and fast
they are api are like
excuse me so you say
both are high performance and
lightweight python web frameworks okay
they are both micro frameworks and are
stripped down without all the bells and
whistles so it allows for for
flexibility
then she says tell me how they are
different
and you say
okay like one is battle tested uh the
other one's a little newer one comes
with lots of built-in libraries like uh
fast api and the other you have to
install some extensions
so the eve winner in icd scrunches her
nose at you and she then demands you to
tell her
how to get a quick hello world
application up and running in both flask
2.0 and fast api
so you say
okay there's two things you understand
to understand when running your hello
world application
the first are decorator or sorry sorry
the first is a decorator and decorators
are functions which modify the
functionality of other functions and
they start with the at symbol followed
by the name of the decorator
you continue you can think of it like
decorating a cake right it starts with
something
then you modify it by adding the
frosting and the flowers and the
sprinkles and the drizzle or whatever
else to put on your cake
the next thing to understand is a route
and so a route maps a function
to a url so it knows which web page to
take the user to making the request
you're on a roll and you're feeling more
confident then you explain
the code right as the evilness lady
gawks at you
and you say okay in flask 2.0 things get
much simpler than previous versions of
flask
for example
route decorators were added for common
http methods like uh
at app.get right and it maps to the
function home
and returns
hello world and versions of flask prior
to 2.0 you'd have to pass in a list
called methods and specify if it's a
pulse or a get
and so this just gets served up on port
5000 by default but you can always
change the ports if you'd like
flash 2.0 is very similar to fast api
with the simple get rot route okay now
from the beginning
fast api uses
an http method in the route like here at
app.git
in fast api all the http verbs get pulse
put delete patch etc have their own
decorators uh and just this just returns
a dictionary with hello world as you see
here
and fast api gets served up on 48 000 by
default but you can change the port and
it just returns hello world as you see
both require little code to get a hello
world up up and running so
uh yeah so this is virtually for
hollywood application both are very
similar
so the evil eyes lady is looking even
more evil and she says let's see what
you know about running in development
from the terminal
to run in development from the terminal
and flask from the command line you'd
have to export your main python file
which in this case is app.py
then you would run the flask development
server by running flask run
but if you want to make a code change
you have to keep restarting the
development server every time so in
order to keep the development server
running you have to export
development into a variable called flask
underscore env
with fast api running and development is
pretty awesome uh because fast api uses
something called hot reloading
and hobby loading keeps that running
when you're making live code changes so
you don't have to keep restarting the
development server so it saves a lot of
time
and so all you have to do is and fast
api for hobby loading to keep that dev
server running is to just pass in the
reload flag in the terminal and to start
the server you would type unicorn main
colon app or whatever the name of your
um
application name is in this case it's
main
sorry your application file in this case
it's main.py
and you can think of uv corn as a
lightning fast server that allows your
applications to perform faster
so hot reloading will save you lots of
development time because your
application reloads automatically
anytime you change the code
evil eye city says that is correct but
how would you execute an http method
like a post request
so http methods are action oriented
verbs right we've covered already how to
do a git which is read only uh now let's
look at a post method okay which creates
data
so let's see how to do a post in both
flask and fast api
uh and a post request is just for
creating a resource like submitting data
like a form to the server
and so let's say we have a list of
dictionary called teams so i told you
you see a lot of sports references here
and here's the first one uh so team name
milwaukee bucks team play uh player
giannis age 26
in previous versions of flash you'd have
to pass in a list called methods to the
decorator and specify the type of
request which is post
but flat supernal makes it much easier
just like we saw with our get request
and all you have to do is specify the
http method
posts in the decorator like at app post
uh and this is the new team you're
passing in or you're creating right
you're adding to your existing list of
dictionaries and you just return it
using jsonify
um and if you
put the browser but if you build the
browser and you go to that this route
you actually get the 405
method down the ladder because this is a
post request and by pulling up a web
page that's doing a get request
so then you'll have to use an external
tool like postman
right which acts as a client so you can
see your pulse requests and the data
that you created in json format
blast 2.0 is very much like fast api
with one exception when it comes to post
requests so as i said earlier fast api
provides separate decorators right for
each http method
uh so with fast api you don't have to
use a tool like pulsman to touch your
post requests so the evo nice lady
interrupts you and she says
yes i know with fast apart you don't
need pulse man
so tell me how would you test your pulse
request using automatic documentation
you take a deep breath right because you
know this answer will be important and
you can't screw up now
so you explain
automatic documentation okay it's an
interactive api documentation where you
can see the results of your
uh
of your
requests such as post requests and then
interact with them in the browser
by passing in data and seeing what you
get back or the response
of that object
it's like magic really right it's going
to make your life easier and you don't
need tools like postman with fast api
and this is how automatic documentation
fast api works so
uh fast api is based on something out of
the box called pedantic um so there's
and there's no need to install it
actually um it gets installed when you
install fast api pedantic is a framework
for easily modeling and validating data
um it also does data validation and uses
type hints pedantic does
and so you'll get much friendlier data
validation errors which reduces
debugging time
and tie pins are just what they sound
like right there they hint at the type
of variable you're using
so to
and they also help document your code
and help you catch bugs a lot
sooner
so an example of a type hint would be
this here uh you have this clear
underscore id variable with the type of
but the type integer or it
so pedantic also works together with
something called swagger ui for the
automatic documentation and this allows
you to visualize and interact with your
apis in your browser which is really
cool so to create the pedantic model
for automatic documentation
you use uh pedantic okay and you import
the base model from pythag and then our
class you'll see in the next slide is
going to inherit
from this base model so inheritance
works like this um you know both your
parents have brown eyes it's highly
likely that your inherits are brown eyes
as well it's pretty much the same
as an abducted programming it works
pretty much in a similar way
so here we're actually importing this
base model from pedantic we have a class
called player that inherits from base
model
and we're declaring variables inside as
type ends right like the first one for
example is player underscore name of
type string
and inside our function
definition we have a parameter we're
passing in called request
that is of type player which is our
class name and this is pretty much also
a type head
and it returns a dictionary okay and so
this is like the boring part of
automatic documentation so let's get to
some really
awesome stuff here
so to access your automatic
documentation you just go to your
localhost
slash docs
and you'll
you'll see a um you'll see a schema
right which is like a skeleton for your
model with your variables
and you can see which variables are
required or optional like the required
variables are the ones with the red
stars next to them
you can try it out there's a try it out
button and you can test your api
endpoints by passing in values for the
variables like we did here like playroom
score name michael jordan playroom score
team chicago bulls player age 32 so
we're just passing in those values in
the browser
and then you just click the execute
button
okay and this will give you the response
body
right which is really cool because this
is a poster press um and so this is what
the server would receive for this pulse
request
what's also cool is that you get back
the curl request too excuse me
so it lets you which lets you talk to a
server
by sending data through the command line
and it generates it for you so you don't
have to write it from scratch
uh in flask there's no built-in
feature for documentation
so you have to use something called uh
it's an extension called flash swagger
which requires a lot of configuration
and it it doesn't come out of the box
so automatic documentation
it comes out of the box with fast api
and you don't have to install anything
so the evil internet icd creeps closer
to you and she sticks her icy finger in
your face and she demands you to tell
her about data validation and why it's
important
you continue while data validation uses
our friend pedantic once again
uh an example data
data validation fast api would be
something like this
okay so let's say we we create a class
right once again that inherits from that
base model
once again with high pending variables
inside of the class
and in our function okay we're checking
to see if username is equal to jane doe
and the password is equal to password
one two three four five if it is uh if
these both are
true then it's going to return us a
success message otherwise it's going to
fail
and so we pull up our automatic
documentation once again for data
validation and we click the try it out
button and
let's pass in none
okay we're going to pass a nun to the
username so this should do an error
we're going to keep the password the
same and agree to the terms which was an
optional value but we're just going to
pass in true
and so pedantic will work its magic and
you'll get a friendly error message
telling you exactly what that error is
and this in this case the error is
says expecting the value which is
spot on the money because since we pass
the nun username it's expecting value
in flask pydantic does not come out of
the box so you can install the powerful
pedantic package for data validation
flash by flask
pedantic so with fast api you get
pedantic out of the box which will give
you uh friendly error messages and
reduce the time spent debugging
the evil internet i said is furious and
she calls you a node on then she asks
well what if i want to create a web page
what's this templates folder business
okay you can feel you're coming down the
home stretch now okay you're more
relaxed and you say the templates folder
stores your html files if you want to
build a web application
in flask by default flask looks for h
the html templates in a templates folder
okay and it stores your html files
in flask you have to import render
templates
and then you serve up the html file you
want to render here which in this case
is index.html
on both flask and fast api you have to
use jinja
to display your variables in html and
ginger is just a templating engine that
allows you to write code similar to
python to display html
and so here's an example right of your
html file to display uh variables and
gender just around the variables with
those double curly braces here
uh in fast api you have to explicitly
define the templates folder in your code
so let's look at an example like the
first thing you can do that you should
do actually is create the templates
folder in your project directory just
like we did in flask
then in your code you import
the gender2 templates from fast api
okay next you create a template object
or variable that you can reuse later
and this request type here you see in
the function definition
uh this request type and fast api
you'll pass in that parameter
so
it will help you know to pass in the
requests in that parameter you want
return in the template
and then lastly
you use the template that you just
created earlier to
render and return a template response uh
passing the request
and your player id variable um as like a
pair of like well key value pairs right
as the context
um so you can access it in gender 2 just
the same way that we did in flask
earlier
so with flask you know there's you can
just create this tipless folder and call
render template there's really no need
to um
explicitly explicitly define the
templates folder like we did in fast api
so at this point icelady is standing
directly in front of you and you can
smell her icy broth and with her arms
folded and her veins like popping out of
her forehead she runs last thing running
in production
so in fast api production is pretty
awesome because it uses something called
asgi
which is an interface right that sits
between a python web server and a
framework
and asgi is special because it
uh it allows for um
async python applications
which makes them you know lightning fast
and so
asgi is asynchronous okay and this is
how asynchronous applications work if
you're not familiar
um so imagine this right you have like a
bunch of requests coming in
and they don't have to wait for the
other ones to complete or finish before
they start processing so they overlap
the request overlap and this is actually
much faster
uh with flask they use something called
whiskey
or the python web server gateway
interface and it's been the python
standard for many years
uh whiskey is synchronous okay so it's
the opposite of a synchronous so uh for
example imagine you have a bunch of
requests coming and each request
has to wait for the others before it to
complete
so notice there is no overlap here
so it's not as fast as being
asynchronous
um so asgi makes for faster performance
in your web applications because of the
way that they process requests
asynchronously
the evil ice lady is super angry and she
pulls out her sword and she puts it up
to your neck and says okay i want you to
choose a winner right now
so you think to yourself okay this is a
trick question and you're feeling
conflicted so this is how you answer it
my winner
this is how i would choose
use flask for this
it's battle tested right
it's been around for a long time and
it's reliable
use flask if you want to get a no a
quick prototype of something
use flask for web application
development
use fast api for this
if you want to increase your development
uh speed time
uh
and performance definitely use fast api
use fast api if you want to reduce
errors and bugs
because of lovely pediantic and the type
hinting in offers and the data
validation
use fast api for api development uh
i definitely feel like this you know
fast api will become the standard in the
new future in the near future many years
to come for apa development so
definitely use it for that and use fast
api if you want to get up and running
quickly with the new framework um fast
api is very beginner friendly um so uh
the documentation is absolutely amazing
so if you have a chance go check out the
documentation online um so yes use it
for do you want to get up and running
quickly use fast api
so icelady lunges towards you and you
remember what your tech lead said
earlier
to kill the evil isolated you just say
these words three times melts mouths
mouths
the evil winner guy city melts away
forever
the internet is restored to the world
and you get to binge watch all of your
favorite shows again and you my friend
are the hero
the end
so uh we have a freebie for you um as i
mentioned earlier i work for vonage and
we have a lot of cool apis like video
uh voice sms
um and so if you'd uh like uh here is a
free
coupon code to try our apis you can just
take a screenshot of this uh the coupon
code is in my favorite color in the hot
pink border there you can see uh we give
you 10 euros of free credits
to use our apis to build something you
know some cool stuff uh it's redeemable
until november 5th 2021 i believe yeah
so use it you know uh go and download it
before then then you can use it
um so
thank you so much for your time today
and also thank you to the by uh pi data
global team
for putting together this amazing
conference and for having me as a
speaker this year um and i would love to
hear from you so this is where you can
find me i'm on twitter just at tanya so
reach out and we'll chat about
sports coding fast api flask or whatever
else thank you so much for your time
hey thank you i really love the
storytelling that was great
we we have a question here that i
spotted so roger webb is asking if
there's a way to generate pedentic
models from sql alchemy models and or
swap sql alchemy out for pydentic
ooh i actually don't know actually
that's a good that's a great question
i'm not sure
i i did a did a cheeky google and
actually sebastian ramirez the creator
fast api has a plug-in for sql
for exactly that use case it's
experimental but
um everything that that guy puts out
that is experimental usually is is
pretty good yeah he's really is that the
one he just released like about a month
ago a month or two ago
might be yeah the the yeah the plugin
for that yeah
yeah yeah it's actually really awesome
and maybe uh the last minute question uh
does fast api provide a similar testing
tool uh the similar testing tools as
flask
i believe so yeah pi tasks right is the
default yeah
in the past i've also used like
hypothesis to do automated testing of
like endpoints uh that's like a quite
nice integration so
that's the asynchronous
with uh with and it's called like schema
thesis and then you can just test the
api endpoints which is pretty neat that
is really neat
it's very bad
excellent with this thank you again so
much that was a fantastic talk i hope
you and everybody else enjoy the rest of
the conference and
um yeah see you in the next talk all
right thank you lauren you guys have a
good day a good night